merci d'être avec nous Guillaume Gontard
et je nous accompagner pendant cette
première demi-heure et lui disait
président du groupe écologiste
solidarité et territoire ici au Sénat et
vous êtes rapporteur de la commission
d'enquête sur la rénovation énergétique
on va en parler dans quelques instants
mais d'abord évidemment l'actualité
c'est la réforme des retraites les
débats qui ont donc repris hier dans
l'hémicycle de l'Assemblée nationale
dans une ambiance toujours aussi
houleuse nouvelle suspension de séance
après qu'un député insoumis à traiter
Olivier du soft d'assassins alors il
s'était excusé à la reprise de la séance
mais que pensez-vous de ce genre de
propos
moi je pense que c'est pas c'est pas
acceptable je pense qu'on doit avoir la
place sur un débat un débat serein un
débat d'idées et donc évidemment je
trouve que l'image qui peut être donnée
à travers à travers ses propos et n'est
pas n'est pas bonne et puis je trouve
encore plus dans la situation actuelle
où on a allez 80% de la population qui
est opposée à cette réforme et derrière
tout ça il y a un vrai choix de société
il y a un vrai choix de comment nous
souhaitons vivre de sens que l'on donne
à notre à notre derrière la question de
l'emploi de la question du travail de la
question de ce qu'il y a à côté du
travail et je pense qu'on peut avoir des
arguments on peut débattre et en tout
cas on peut tracer vraiment ce que l'on
souhaite justement pour notre notre
société nous en tout cas c'est comme ça
qu'on travaillera c'est comme ça qu'on
interviendra ici ici au Sénat on va
venir c'est la deuxième fois la semaine
prochaine
et un incident lié à des propos d'un
député de la France insoumise ils vont
trop loin pour vous
après je peux toujours comprendre et je
dirais la le voilà quand on descend une
idée la ferveur qu'on peut avoir après
voilà je pense qu'il faut faire la part
des choses il y a un débat démocratique
qui doit avoir lieu qui est là on peut
se donner des explications des arguments
quand on va sur l'insulte bah non ça ne
fonctionne plus ça ne marche plus quoi
on est on est dans un pays démocratique
l'assemblée là effectivement pour se
dire les choses pour discuter pour
échanger mais certainement pas pour pour
s'investir ou pour s'insulter et les
abeilles borne parce que le sur le fond
l'examen du texte n'avance pas beaucoup
à l'article 2 sur l'index senior n'est
toujours pas voté Elisabeth borgne hier
soir a demandé le retrait des
amendements d'obstruction et la fin des
invectives la nuque en réponse en a
retiré un millier elle avait raison la
première ministre de demander ça
je sais pas si elle avait si elle avait
raison c'est c'est mais je pense qu'il y
a aussi une très grosse responsabilité
de ce gouvernement il faut pas non plus
se le cacher de vouloir comme ça passer
en force c'est sûr que l'opposition on a
assez moyen là c'est à dire à la fois de
gagner du temps à la fois de pouvoir
exposer nos idées mais ce n'est pas rien
donc il faut ce temps-là et ce temps du
débat alors oui on a un temps contraint
et je rappelle que ce temps contraint a
été décidé par la première ministre
notamment avec le 47.1 qui limite le
temps et on aura la même chose au Sénat
donc c'est un choix et une
responsabilité de ce gouvernement de la
première ministre qui quelque part veut
tronquer le débat veut aller plus vite
je dirais que la musique et surtout
surtout une responsabilité immense je ne
sais pas si ce rende compte dans quel
état est notre pays et je dirais je
discutais encore ce week-end avec un
certain nombre de personnes lors de la
manifestation tout le monde en a marre
ne veut pas de cette réforme je veux
dire c'est très clair veut passer à
autre chose on a un vrai problématique
la question du réchauffement climatique
la question du coût de l'énergie la
question de commence je comment mange et
ben ça ce sont des vrais questions
auxquelles les gens aimeraient avoir du
système de retraite c'est pas une vraie
conscience
je dis pas que c'est une pas une vraie
question j'ai que 1 ce n'est pas une
urgence que on est parti tête baissée en
disant ça sera 65 ans ou rien d'autre
bon maintenant c'est 64 sans ouvrir
réellement un vrai débat et donc
effectivement on récupère cette ambiance
là moi j'aurais préféré que le
gouvernement pose tout sur la table et
oui on a des propositions on a des
propositions pour avoir des meilleures
pensions pour avoir un autre type de
financement pour travailler sur la
pénibilité oui effectivement il y a un
chantier qui peut s'ouvrir mais selon
faisons-le sereinement et moi je demande
vraiment solennellement qu'on retire
qu'on retire ce texte qu'on retire cette
réforme et qu'on retrouve un peu de
sérénité vous me demanderez dès
l'ouverture des débats au Sénat bah
évidemment je l'ai déjà demandé
question d'actualité la semaine dernière
à Elizabeth borne parce que je pense
qu'on va droit dans le mur je vais dire
c'est bon pour personne j'ai
certainement pas bon justement pour la
démocratie c'est pas bon pour l'image
qu'on donne et puis encore une fois nos
concitoyens nos concitoyens sont
fatigués quelle sera la stratégie de
votre groupe SMS est-ce que vous allez
déposer des centaines des milliers
d'amendements ou est-ce que vous allez
en déposer on fait le moins possible
pour que encore un débat on a à peu près
15 jours avec une date limite donc on
utilisera tous les moyens qui sont les
moyens parlementaires qui sont à notre
disposition
que ça soit de dépôt d'amendement je
peux vous dire ça sera pas des
amendements on change une virgule on
change voilà mais en fait nous qu'on a
toujours travaillé comme ça moi je le
dis toujours on est évidemment un groupe
d'opposition mais on est d'abord un
groupe de propositions et nous on sait
ce qu'on veut on sait ce qu'on sait ce
qu'il y a derrière et quels sont nos
choix de société et à travers ces
amendements à travers nos discours à
travers nos interventions on montrera
justement qu'il y a d'autres possibilité
mobilité d'autres choix que de nous dire
que après le travail bien c'est la mort
ou le néant est-ce que vous ferez tout
pour que l'examen de ce texte n'arrive
pas au bout au Sénat
du débat ça devrait de la discussion
puisque maintenant qu'il n'y a plus
qu'une seule majorité je dirais puisque
maintenant les LR font partie de la
majorité c'est ce qu'ils ont quasi
annoncé puis toute façon en appuyant
quand on quand on vote un texte comme ça
je pense que c'est très clair toute
façon on le voit depuis un certain temps
donc
c'est exactement ce qu'ils ont voté
depuis quatre ans alors ce que je
constate d'ailleurs c'est qu'on les en
pas on s'entend pas trop sur les
territoires je veux dire moi je me
balade pas mal en ce moment j'entends
très peu justement les républicains
avancées argumenter sur cette réforme
des retraites et ils se font plutôt très
discret alors est-ce qu'il s'aperçoivent
qu'effectivement c'est peut-être pas la
bonne solution en tout cas ça fera
partie des débats qu'on aura ici au
Sénat
du texte Sénat le les syndicats
appellent à mettre la France à l'arrêt
c'est une stratégie que vous approuvez
un moment donné quand un gouvernement
comme ça veuillez tête baissée ne veut
rien changer et puis surtout dans ses
argumentations ce qui s'est passé avec
les mises 200 euros le mensonge
d'Olivier Véran ça pose quand même un
problème en terme de clarification de
qu'est-ce qu'on veut vraiment derrière
cette de derrière cette de cette réforme
les éléments qui sont annoncés et puis
après on nous dit ah ben non ça sera pas
tout à fait comme ça plus personne ne
comprend rien donc encore une fois
j'espère vraiment qu'on arrivera pas un
blocage du pays c'est bon pour personne
donc encore une fois la responsabilité
est dans le camp du gouvernement on va
passer à l'actualité du Sénat cette
semaine puisqu'il y a vous avez
auditionné cinq anciens ministres de
l'écologie et du Logement puisque vous
êtes rapporteur de la commission
d'enquête sur l'efficacité des
politiques publiques en matière de
rénovation énergétique on revient sur
ces auditions avec notre journaliste
parlementaire Alex où ça
[Musique]
bonjour Ariane bonjour Guillaume Gontard
bonjour et Alexia la commission
d'enquête du Sénat sur la rénovation
énergétique a donc auditionné d'anciens
ministres en charge de ce dossier
qu'est-ce qu'il a sorti de ces auditions
et bien en fait une seule question au
fond a été posée à ses anciennes
ministres du logement et de l'écologie
une seule question posée par les
sénateurs comment se fait-il qu'en
France en 2022 il y a encore 5,2
millions de passwords thermiques 17% du
parc de logement avec une trop forte
consommation énergétique alors même que
depuis des années il y a des lois
écologiques en faveur du logement pour
permettre aux Français de rénover ces
bâtiments écoutez la réponse d'Emmanuel
wargon qui était ministre du logement
dans le premier quinquennat d'Emmanuel
Macron on peut mettre tous les objectifs
législatifs qu'on veut on peut mettre
des chiffres dans les lois successives
la loi elle-même est pas
auto-réalisatrice et donc il suffit pas
de dire que on rénove 500 000 logements
par an dans la loi ou que il n'y aura
plus de passoire thermique 10 ans après
le vote du noir pour que tout ceci se
produise
c'est un sujet qui est un sujet de moyen
d'exécution et de système un sujet qui
se règle par des moyens et c'est cette
question budgétaire qui a posé des
problèmes à Cécile Duflot lorsqu'elle
était ministre du logement dans le
gouvernement de Jean-Marc Ayrault
souffrances Hollande les objectifs
étaient fixés pour aider les Français à
rénover leur logement mais les moyens
mis en oeuvre ne suffisaient pas en
cause selon l'écologie socio et bien le
ministère de l'économie et des finances
écoutez-la je dois lui dire mes
discussions budgétaires avec les
différents ministres du Budget ont
toujours été parfois
désespérante la norme de dépenses
puisque c'est comme ça qui convient de
parler étant la chose la plus stupide
que j'ai connue dans ma vie parce que
quand vous avez vous êtes capable de
prouver qu'un investissement d'un euro
d'argent public peut rapporter 1,3 euros
d'argent public à échéance 5 ans
n'importe quel investisseur n'importe
lequel signe dans la seconde n'importe
lequel sauf l'état alors même si ce
manque de moyens budgétaire est pointé
du doigt on peut rappeler quand même que
depuis des années chaque année entre 4
milliards d'euros et 7 milliards d'euros
et dépensés en argent public pour
financer cette rénovation énergétique
des bâtiments donc il y a quand même des
moyens sur la table mais il y a aussi
d'autres problèmes qui sont soulevés
dans ces auditions et notamment un souci
de complexité des aides ces dernières
années pour et bien changer rénover ces
passoires thermiques on s'est retrouvé
pas dans ces aides et même pas la
ministre en charge du dossier la
ministre de l'écologie qui arrivait aux
manettes en 2020 Barbara pompelli
écoutez là sur son expérience personnel
il s'avère que moi je l'ai expérimenté à
titre personnel et que même moi qui suis
quand même plutôt sensibilisée au sujet
j'ai pas réussi à avoir toutes les aides
auxquelles je pouvais prétendre et j'ai
loupé des trucs parce que j'ai mal
rempli enfin bon donc je me dis si même
quelqu'un de au courant comme moi
n'arrive pas à obtenir des aides vous
imaginez bien des gens qui n'ont pas la
même connaissance du sujet voilà alors
pour simplifier le système le
gouvernement a créé ma prime rénov cette
aide financière que les propriétaires
peuvent solliciter pour rénover leur
logement et qui est dégressive en
fonction de leurs revenus beaucoup de
projets ont été financés avec ma prime
rénov 644 000 en 2021 mais au final le
bilan est assez maigre puisque seulement
2500 logements sont sortis véritablement
de ce statut de passoire thermique donc
le dispositif n'est pas encore très
efficace Guillaume Gontard au terme de
ces auditions cette semaine et la
semaine dernière de nombreux ministres
en de ces questions de rénovation
énergétique des logements quelle faille
dans les systèmes dans les dispositifs
qui ont été mis en place vous commencez
à percevoir
ce que je trouve intéressant à travers
ces nombreuses auditions qui se sont qui
se sont succédées c'est bon évidemment
que chaque ministre défend un petit peu
le dispositif qu'il a pu mettre en place
et donc cette succession en fait de
dispositifs mais ce qui ressort c'est
justement c'est d'avoir de la lisibilité
et du et de travailler sur le temps long
et ça c'est vraiment quelque chose dont
on a dont on a besoin et financièrement
aussi d'avoir une ligne financière c'est
ce que disait Cécile Duflot d'avoir un
budget pour une année mais de savoir que
le budget ne sera peut-être pas
forcément renouvelé bah c'est
catastrophique parce qu'on a tout un
dispositif du coup qui s'écroule
derrière et qui ne peut pas se
poursuivre
exactement et je crois qu'il y a deux
trois ministres qui l'ont dit très
clairement oui évidemment qu'il faut une
loi de une noix de programmation c'est
une demande enfin je pense que là ça
fait quasi l'unanimité ensuite il y a la
porte d'entrée c'est à dire que ça soit
simple on sache à qui s'adresser qu'on
est alors soit un numéro de téléphone
soit alors c'est avec France rénov qui
est en train de se mettre de se mettre
en place mais en tout cas d'avoir
quelque chose de très lisible pour pour
les personnes pour les bailleurs pour
que voilà on sait à qui on s'adresse et
ensuite on est on est orienté et puis à
la question du financement parce que oui
il y a eu entre 5 et 7 milliards qui ont
pu être injectés il y a la question
d'efficacité c'est à quoi réellement ont
servi ces milliards et notamment
s'aperçoit qu'on ne va pas vraiment sur
de la rénovation rénovation globale et
Emmanuel vargon le disait je lui ai posé
la question on disait il faudrait au
moins un milliard supplémentaire sur la
rénovation globale pour cibler vraiment
cette rénovation globale mais aussi
parce que c'est vrai et ça ça a été dit
c'est qu'on a besoin aussi d'avoir des
gestes parce que des personnes vont
commencer à réhabiliter leur logement on
peut pas forcément tout faire d'un coup
et c'est mais par contre on a besoin
d'un accompagnement on a besoin d'avoir
de l'ingénierie derrière pour dire voilà
comment il faut faire voilà par quoi il
faut commencer et voilà quels sont les
étapes justement pour arriver à cette
rénovation à cette rénovation globale il
y a une question aussi de compétence
humaine de professionnels formés on
entendait hier dans cette audition
Emmanuel wargon dire que il n'y avait
pas assez d'artisans qualifiés pour
réaliser ce qu'on appelle les
diagnostics de les diagnostics pardon de
performance énergétique justement cette
évaluation des passoires thermiques donc
il y a un problème de compétences on a
vu sur les DPE et les diagnostics
justement sur lequel la première vague
de DPE où on a bien vu il y a une une
étude de Que Choisir qui a montré que
c'était un petit peu aléatoire et à
cette réforme des DPE qui est importante
parce que derrière en fait on a besoin
d'avoir des choses très claires et
affirmer sur est-ce que ce logement il
est en classe G e AB ou voilà mais on a
besoin que ça soit très clair et je
dirais incontestable puisque c'est
derrière à travers ça qu'on va mettre en
place ces politiques ces politiques
publiques donc la réforme des DPE est en
cours en tout cas il est en train d'être
modifié il va falloir voir effectivement
si ça fonctionne réellement mais c'est
quelque chose effectivement d'important
et puis après il y a aussi toute la
question de la filière c'est à dire des
entreprises donc là on aura évidemment
des auditions sur les représentants des
différents corps de corps de métier
parce que là aussi à la question de la
formation la question de la capacité à
pouvoir faire parce que c'est vrai que
derrière ces milliards il faut des
femmes des hommes qui puissent faire ses
travaux qui puissent les accompagner et
donc il faut aussi que cette filière se
structure et se structure aussi à
travers les territoires également aussi
sur la disponibilité en termes de
matériaux mais c'est aussi une réflexion
qu'on doit avoir sur les territoires sur
comment on développe de nouvelles
filières de fabrication de matériaux
peut-être en étant un petit peu plus un
peu plus local donc c'est aussi ce qui
est intéressant à travers ça à travers
la rénovation thermique on touche un
spectre très large avec évidemment de
l'emploi à la clé avec une structuration
sur les territoires donc quand Cécile
disait du flow disait faites voilà quand
on met 1 € sur la table on en génère
trois quatre à la fois dans la filière
du bâtiment sur les territoires on
génère du confort chez soi on agit aussi
sur la santé parce que c'est quelque
chose qui a été dit très clairement
c'est vrai qu'un logement quand on parle
d'une passoire thermique ben un logement
insalubre bah ça a un impact sur la
santé et la santé c'est un impact aussi
sur notre budget à long terme l'objectif
de votre commission d'enquête c'est de
comprendre pourquoi la France n'atteint
pas ses objectifs en matière de
rénovation énergétique alors on l'a
entendu hier il y a des questions sur un
manque de moyens sur une politique des
politiques publiques qui sont peu
efficaces et pourtant on l'a vu les
ministres qui étaient en charge de ces
dossiers Barbara pompigny Emmanuel cosse
et sil Duflot ce sont des figures de
l'écologie c'était des figures de
l'écologie comment vous expliquer que
même elle n'est pas réussi à mener à
bien sa politique ouais c'est un petit
peu le constat qu'on a pu faire hier
mais même qui est un constat partagé
c'était de dire que justement à travers
l'ensemble de ces ministres
on peut dire que le sujet de la
rénovation thermique est partagé
politiquement je connais pas grand monde
qui dit non il faut pas aller vers ça il
faut pas travailler sur cette révélation
thermique et donc même quand on a un
sujet qui fait quasi consensus on voit
qu'on a du mal on a du mal concrètement
à le mettre en place donc c'est
évidemment pour ça aussi qu'on s'est
décidé à faire cette commission
d'enquête c'est d'essayer de comprendre
pourquoi parce qu'il ressort quand même
c'est effectivement c'est le fait qu'on
doit avoir et on doit pouvoir travailler
sur du temps long avoir des objectifs
sur du temps long et ne pas revenir sans
cesse en arrière ne pas construire en
fait des usines à gaz qui sont lequel
personne se reconnaît quoi
merci regarde à tout à l'heure on
parlera d'accès aux soins exactement
puisque c'est un débat tout à l'heure au
Sénat merci beaucoup Alex d'avoir été
avec nous on va voir l'actualité dans
votre département de l'Isère maintenant
Guillaume Gontard grâce à nos
partenaires de la presse régionale on va
à Grenoble où on retrouve Jean Benoît
Vigny bonjour merci beaucoup d'être avec
nous journaliste au Dauphiné Libéré et à
lire ce matin dans vos pages un dossier
sur le prix des loyers dans le sud de
l'Isère
oui en effet on parle des loyers parce
que depuis six ans il y a l'Observatoire
des loyers qui a été mis en place sur 75
communes en gros il prend le pouls et
chaque année il livre les chiffres des
loyers dans ces communes là que vous
voyez sur vous voyez la carte sur notre
page ce matin alors l'agglomération de
grenobloise qui est là en gros la 15e en
France elle est au niveau des prix là
onzième et la ville de Grenoble elle est
encore un peu plus haute elle est elle
est neuvième avec un prix moyen de 11
euros sur le département et un peu plus
sur Grenoble et encore plus évidemment
dans l'hyper centre cette observatoire
il a pas été mis en place seulement pour
qu'on fasse des jolis dossiers et des
jolies cartes dans le Dauphiné libéré il
a été mis en place parce que le la
métropole veut souhaite en tout cas la
majorité l'encadrement des loyers et la
demander en 2021 à la ministre Emmanuel
le dragon vous avez vu tout à l'heure
sauf qu'elle l'a retoquée elle n'a pas
voulu parce qu'elle n'a pas estimé que
le marché était assez tendu pour autant
la métropole
accident domestique la métropole
redemande l'encadrement des loyers
au nouveau ministre du Logement
Guillaume retard je suppose que vous
êtes vous-même favorable à cette mesure
mais est-ce que c'est pas finalement un
gadget alors que le la priorité c'est
peut-être de d'abord de construire du
logement parce qu'on en manque à
Grenoble comme ailleurs en France
encore une fois je pense que c'est c'est
les deux c'est de dire que effectivement
il y a un besoin il y a un besoin de
logement c'est évident mais il y a aussi
un besoin d'encadrement de ses loyers
mais je trouve que derrière ça c'est
vrai que ça a été dit ça a été demandé
en 2021 par la métropole par la Ville de
Grenoble de pouvoir expérimenté parce
que c'est une expérimentation sur sur
les territoires cette encadrement des
loyers ça a été refusé il y a une
nouvelle demande et je pense qu'à un
moment donné il faut aussi laisser la
place et ça c'est peut-être aussi une
manière peut-être un peu différente de
faire de de la politique et de laisser
la main au territoire et là c'est ce que
demande bah les élus de dire
laissez-nous utiliser cette
expérimentation et laissez-nous la
mettre en place et puis bah comme toute
expérimentation bah ça permet de voir
effectivement si ça fonctionne c'est il
y a une action mais on a une vraie
nécessité d'agir sur le sur la question
des loyers parce que ça a été dit sur la
ville centre sur Grenoble sur les zones
urbaines mais on le voit aussi se
déplacer avec un vrai problème de
comment on vit au pays et comment on
peut rester au pays avec des loyers même
dans des territoires ruraux j'en fais
partie qui sont très élevés alors
évidemment moins élevé qu'à Grenoble
mais qui reste très élevé en tout cas
pour les populations qui sont là et
notamment aussi avec le développement
des résidences secondaires notre notre
groupe au Sénat a déposé un avait déposé
un texte justement pour permettre à la
fois de donner des possibilités
financières aux collectivités de pouvoir
agir sur la politique du logement à la
fois à travers de la construction mais
aussi pour pouvoir agir en termes
d'autonomie financière notamment sur la
taxation la possibilité de taxation sur
les résidences secondaires et notamment
la décorrélation entre la taxe foncière
sur le sur le bâti principal et
résidence secondaire parce
qu'actuellement les deux sont liés et on
a plein de collectivités et notamment en
zone aussi touristique pour loger
notamment par exemple les les
saisonniers où on a besoin voilà d'avoir
ce moyen ce moyen d'action donc en tout
cas c'est un sujet qui rejoint
d'ailleurs notre commission d'enquête
aussi parce que derrière la rénovation
thermique on se pose aussi ces questions
là sur le coup justement et sur la
manière de pouvoir se loger
autre a atteindre dans le Dauphiné
Libéré cette question est-ce qu'on
respire bien à Grenoble
on sait en tout cas posé la question
hier parce que Grenoble n'est pas en
vigilance pollution vous savez c'est une
ville qui a la réputation d'être très
polluée d'abord par son sa zone
géographique elle est entourée dans une
cuvette elle entourée par les montagnes
or Lyon est en vigilance pollution
Strasbourg je crois valet la Drôme est
en alerte rouge en biligence rouge et
pas Grenoble on s'est demandé donc
pourquoi est-ce qu'on respirait
visiblement mieux à Grenoble aujourd'hui
qu'ailleurs alors la réponse est assez
compliquée parce que au niveau de des
conditions météo elles sont favorables à
la pollution en ce moment avec
l'anticyclone on sait donc posé la
question de savoir si c'était les
mesures qui avaient été mises en place
il y a déjà une ZF mobilité agronome il
y a une primaire bois pour essayer de
limiter les problèmes des combustions de
foyers ouverts la réponse elle est pas
simple toujours est-il qu'il n'y a pas
de vigilance pollution en ce moment par
contre il y a de la pollution c'est ça
la difficulté et la difficulté à
comprendre pour le grand public c'est
que la pollution sur les particules
fines les particules fines PM c'est à
dire les plus fines elle existe elle est
belle et bien là Grenoble et bel et bien
pollué en ce moment assez particulier
mais ça ne déclenche pas de vigilance
préfectorale ce n'est pas encore dans le
protocole on va dire préfectoral et du
coup on se retrouve avec une situation
paradoxale ou Grenoble reste pollué mais
sans que les habitants soient vraiment
vraiment au grand sinon en lisant Le
Dauphiné Libéré ce matin du coup
Guillaume comptaert ce thermomètre
est-ce que est-ce qu'il faut le revoir
est-ce qu'il faut aller plus loin est-ce
que finalement on ne prend pas assez au
sérieux cette question de la qualité de
l'air bah la question de la qualité de
l'air elle est essentielle donc oui je
pense que alors le thermomètre il est le
même pour pour tout le monde la question
c'est qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce qu'on
regarde
directement effectivement la question
des particules fines donc moi je suis
tout à fait d'accord pour dire qu'il
faut peut-être revoir effectivement
cette cette question de ce qu'on calcule
de ce qu'on regarde et à quel moment
justement on se met en on se met en
vigilance mais la pollution de l'air en
France être entre 40
décès par an c'est à peu près ce que
voilà la période du covid c'est les
mêmes décès qu'il y avait pendant le
covid et on voit pendant le covid ce
qu'on a pu mettre en place en termes de
politique publique donc oui on a besoin
d'agir d'agir vite d'agir très fort sur
cette question de la pollution de l'air
parce que ça a un impact sur la santé
sur la vie sur la vie des gens je
constate quand même que la métropole
grenobloise a déjà fait des efforts vous
avez parlé de la ZFE qui est un gros
sujet sur lequel en tout cas il y a il y
a encore il y a encore à dire il y a
encore à faire mais qui a déjà des
résultats il y a déjà des résultats sur
la qualité de l'air sur la métropole
Greno basse qui sont pas suffisants
évidemment parce qu'en plus on a une par
particularité géographique sur sur la
métropole grenobloise mais en tout cas
on a déjà des résultats merci
loyer ou payez-vous le plus cher en
Sud-Isère c'est à la une du Dauphiné
Libéré ce matin merci d'avoir été avec
nous depuis Grenoble un dernier mot on
va parler des sénatoriales puisque ça
arrive c'est dans six mois Guillaume
gonta Yannick Jadot a officialisé son
souhait d'être candidat au sénatorial à
Paris mais il n'est pas le seul vous
souhaitez que ça soit lui
l'objectif d'une vingtaine et pas et pas
totalement fou alors voilà moi je
préfère me donner des objectifs très
forts mais en tout cas je sais que ce
groupe se renforcera qu'il a sa place
qu'il est maintenant implanté ici au
Sénat et que la voix de l'écologie
politique elle a son importance ici un
dernier mot vous souhaitez des listes
communes avec l'ensemble de la gauche ou
des listes écologistes
moi je suis toujours favorable à ce
qu'on se regroupe et que la gauche et
les écologistes puissent se regrouper
après il y a des discussions qui se font
par département parce qu'il y a des
particularités par département et que
c'est vrai que l'élection sénatoriale
reste une élection un petit peu
particulière et puis nous on aura un
sujet aussi sur la parité sur la place
sur la place des femmes parce que c'est
vrai qu'on a un groupe qui n'est pas
totalement paritaire et sur lequel il
faut qu'on progresse donc ça sera aussi
un enjeux
et qu'on priorise en tout cas cela parce
que c'est vrai que voilà il faut qu'on
rééquilibre et ce qui est tout à fait
normal merci
minutes sur l'accès aux soins
soins pour protester notamment contre
une réforme qui facilite l'accès pour
les patients à des soignants
paramédicaux le texte est examiné
aujourd'hui au Sénat on en débat dans 20
minutes d'abord on accueille notre
prochaine invité c'est Julien Robert